go back to the past to defeats again in
the future if I do this I'm going back
to some crazy time sabotage after
Thanksgiving tradition called sleeping
so what's up it's good
trust us detective well it occurred to
me that if you'll consume a damn
west-allen you want to spend this
holiday with your family
well perhaps no Medicare does well so I
had mr. Sisco hack into the CCTV footage
of the occipital and this is what we got
ever since grace arrived only one man
has come to visit her every day
including tonight
team flash I give you Arlen Dwyer also
known as hey everybody its charlie we
finally got a trailer for the flash
100th episode I'll take one reverse
flash versus one zoom versus once avatar
versus one Barry Allen to go so it'll be
fun to see how this all fits together
and why it's so important that Barry go
back to visit these different villains
to find out how to defeat cicada in the
future there's a new brand of that flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video so we'll just go
through this shot by shot so you start
out with them at the beginning of season
one working through all the WTF moments
that Barry has had as he's narrating to
Nora in the team if we do this we're
gonna have to go back and see some
really crazy stuff so while he's
flipping through this picture book of
memories they go frame by frame with a
bunch of different shots you start out
with the particle accelerator explosion
you see the Mardon brothers weather
wizard that we just saw during episode 7
and his brother clyde mardon getting
their powers barry getting struck by
lightning the creation of firestorm back
during season one that we saw when
Ronnie got his powers for the first time
that was also the night of the particle
accelerator explosion there is a brief
shot and present day of Barry looking
through the window at cicada and him
looking down at him so this might be at
the beginning of the episode because
they just found out who he is so that
means the Barry's got to confront him
and find out that there is something
that he needs that he doesn't have in
present-day and that's where they come
up with the idea go back to the past to
figure out how to defeat cicada in the
future so there has to be some moment
where they justify that maybe it has
something to do with Barry not having a
countermeasure for the abilities that
his dagger gives him stealing his Speed
Force energy any time he gets close or
maybe it's just because cicada is now
physically too powerful because he is
growing stronger as he gets sicker and
sicker so the closer he gets to death
however long that takes
he'll just become more and more Opie
then he starts talking about going back
into the past again and you get all the
big flash villains in Reverse starting
with Savitt are during season 3 I didn't
know for sure whether or not they were
going to include him in the episode but
the official synopsis that they released
for it I did a video for last week sort
of confirm
they'd be visiting all the biggest
moments in the Flash's history so he
being a really big moment implied that
he was gonna be in the episode but all
we see here is a clip from season 3 we
don't know how they're gonna invoke him
physically in the episode if they're
just gonna run through a scene from
season 3 or if they shot new footage
with somebody in the Salvatore costume
he mentions dawn from season 1 this is I
think another clip from the back half of
season 1 not new footage that they've
shot because I mean Tom Cavanagh has an
age that much in a couple years so he
doesn't look that different than when he
did during season 1 this is definitely
clip of zoom from I think the last
couple of episodes when Barry gave him
his power for the last time this was
before he got sucked up into the Speed
Force which they referenced during
episode 7 because episode 7 was all
about Barry maybe dying every time he
ran into battle to try and save people
and Nora being okay with that
so Barry getting sucked into the Speed
Force during season 2 was one of the
references that iris made when she was
trying to talk to Nora about it but this
scene with Nora is a new scene who is
this with like that deep gravelly voice
so they got Teddy Sears to come back to
do the episode that is a bit of a
surprise we knew that Tony Todd was
gonna be coming back because he's the
one that spilled the beans on zoom being
a big part of the episode I love the
look on Nora's face though she looks
kind of excited and kind of scared at
the same time because she's been reading
about all these major flash villains in
the flash museum her whole life but
she's never met them in the flesh that
we know of I still have some theories
about who's manipulating Nora in the
future that she has not told us about
yet they raised that question in the
first couple of episodes the synopsis
for the episode also reveals that
Sherlock wells raises that issue with
iris wondering who that mystery person
in the future is that told Nora that she
had powers and gave her the idea to come
back into the past there's the scene
from the end of season 3 when they took
down saboteur and destroyed his suit and
everybody wonders how the completed one
got into the flash museum I'm assuming
that they put it back together or it's a
replica
Cisco writing the dates might be him
just trying to plot out where in history
Barry needs to travel to specifically
the person with the hat looks a little
bit like Sherlock wells in present-day
this might be them staking out cicada
Cisco in his vibe gear at what looks
like the hospital this also might be in
present-day iris
from the end of season three when she
shots avatar in the back cicada looking
like this is also from present-day this
is probably some big showdown that they
have at the hospital like when they all
converge on him at the beginning of the
episode more of the season three finale
battle with Savitt are with them running
through the trees then berry in an
alleyway cursing their idea I knew we
shouldn't have done this
so obviously something goes completely
off the rails of course traveling back
in time one is already kind of bad but
two he's also interacting with all these
evil speedsters that almost were able to
kill him on several occasions this shot
of cicadas dagger seems like it's from
earlier in the season then we have a
shot of berries legs sticking out in the
old flash costume for behind a dumpster
maybe when they come back into the past
they have to knock out the current
version of Barry Allen so that they can
move around freely because he doesn't
look that much older he can actually
masquerade as the earlier version of
himself they tried that during season 1
until the time wraiths came and that's
what alerted the reverse-flash to his
presence like you are definitely not the
version of Barry Allen that I've been
talking to the last year so you were
from the future why did you come back
here then speak of the devil there in
the Time Vault with Nora and he says
things just got a lot more complicated
he's smiling like a psychopath because
of course he'd be smiling if Barry Allen
has some problem that he's dealing with
he really loves watching Barry be in
turmoil but also he loves being the
smartest person in the room
so it's icing on the cake that Barry's
come crawling on his knees to get his
help with something
so you have to remember that the Wells
version of the reverse-flash was
probably from the latest in his timeline
so he's been through a lot more than the
younger versions of eobard thawne that
we saw during season 2 in our legends of
tomorrow so he has a record of all the
things that happen with cicada but
because of where he is and the way that
North's messing with the timeline those
changes have not caught up with him yet
so even though he has this crazy
advanced science that can probably help
them find a solution to defeat cicada
eventually if cicada is able to change
the timeline enough then his future
would be erased and he would slowly
disappear but that would probably just
take a little while longer but I'm still
holding out hope that after they're done
with it they used cicadas dagger to turn
into the reverse flashes wand from the
comics he has this lightning-shaped wand
it's really silly it's a relic of the
Silver Age so they tried to use it in a
funny way when Geoff
brought barry allen back during rebirth
back in 2009 so he uses it to slice up a
whole bunch of people and create the
negative speed force so this was just
speculation but for now this seems like
the version of the reverse-flash that
we're going to see still hoping to find
out what his new face is going to look
like because that was the big teaser and
last year's crossover I wonder what my
face will look like the next time we
meet I don't know that I absolutely need
to do an episode 7 video they did a lot
of great things it was a Thanksgiving
themed one I've already talked a lot
about weather which in all the trailer
videos that I did last week there's just
so much stuff happening right now that
I'm trying to prioritize so if you have
any questions about episode 7 also leave
those on this video but if they post any
more footage or any other cool stuff
from the hundredth episode I'll do a
video for that later click here for that
new Elseworlds trailer and click here
for that new Thor Stormbreaker deleted
scene from infinity war thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
see you guys tonight
[Music]